I'm going to go with Steve W trob
collider how are you doing arch nemesis
oh this is you know this is uh Die Hard
Alan Rickman y you know yep got it so
listen I want to start with first of all
uh congratulations on this movie you I
mean you know how incredible it is I'm
sure you've seen it you know you know
it's just amazing thank you for the
interview it's great next exactly before
before I have I have a question
obviously about Dune but you know that I
Super Fan of Silo also and I would
imagine that's why you are not in Los
Angeles right now so I can't tell you
what I've been doing but my God and from
6:00 this morning until literally I
rocked up 5 minutes before we
started I can't tell you but let's say
were you swimming in water yes have you
read the books no I'm just saying like
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
know you're going to end up in water in
season two well come on don't be that
guy but yes I have been submerged
in water exactly very deep when do you
actually finish filming on that the 8th
of March thank you very much for asking
oh my God so yeah that means I'm not
seeing it until the end of the year or
the beginning of the following let's
move on I was just that's another sorry
we don't who you know that's that this
is now yeah totally as a
fan so one of the things one of the
things I really want to touch on is what
I love about Frank's writing with Dune
is that like the way he talks about the
Benny Jester it and their plans the way
they lay plans for like thousands of
years the way they use religion as a
tool I know
tolerance yeah can you sort of talk
about like just how smart the the
writing is and the Benny jessits in
general I mean it's more what I find
interesting is the idea that
people had to be so tolerant and so
ahead of the game and we often talk
about being 10 steps ahead we're talking
about being years and light years ahead
of planting ideas and well religious
thoughts but one of the scenes that we
didn't get in which was one of my
favorite ones from the book and I tried
to get us to get it in but it's a big
moment it's the communication of one
benages to another underneath a leaf the
sign language do you
remember from the book yes but there's a
lot of stuff that Deni can't get into
this film I know yeah you know you know
tried but you know there's there's a
series that they're doing for Max and
maybe they'll work it in with the series
I mean well that doesn't give anything
to me does it what I'm grateful for them
I mean what am I going to be happy for
other
people okay so let me switch to
something else so you see the shooting
the shooting schedule for for movie for
part two uhhuh what is the what is the
day you have circled in terms of I
cannot wait to film this or oh my God we
have to film this I think for me it was
definitely the
transformation of Lady
Jessica um going through the whole
Reverend mother process um it was sort
of underlined circled highlighted
exclamation mark and copied and then
laminated um it's probably one of the
best scenes I've done in a long time and
there's a lot of things we did that
didn't really make it but we worked with
with contortionists and movement and and
I think they had to shorten it but my
God it was literally like some form of
Exorcist movie with how um how we moved
it was great I really mean this congrats
on this movie uh it's fantastic and you
know I wish you nothing but the best
thank you
honey